we are getting our first look at an
accused child molester this is a story
the i-team first broke wednesday the
i-team's vanessa murphy joins us in
studio with more on evidence police and
prosecutors say they have nasa
asher dezan's defense attorney
previously pointed to a lack of evidence
saying the alleged victim needed
counseling and was manipulated by her
mom who poisoned her kids minds but that
was before police were able to get into
the suspect's phone where they say they
uncovered numerous images of the 35 year
old man sexually assaulting the
ten-year-old girl there were so many
videos on this guy's phone of him
molesting this girl that we had to cut
it off at a certain point clark county
chief deputy district attorney jake
valani explaining why the case against
asher dezan was narrowed down to a 26
day time period dezan faces 93 charges
including sexual assault against a child
under the age of 14 lewdness with the
child and more they're all on video and
they're all identifiable of the
defendant dezan was not in court for
this bail hearing wednesday he was in
quarantine at the clark county detention
center fulani argued for a 5 million
dollar bill pointing to the severity of
the charges some carrying a sentence of
35 years to life his defense attorney
nicholas wooldridge argued for a one
hundred thousand dollar bill saying
dezan has deep ties in the las vegas
community he's a business owner selling
cell phone accessories and his wife is
supporting him the judge set bail at one
million dollars with high level
electronic monitoring the next court
date for dezan is september 14th i'm
concerned about the community here
obviously given his conduct i'm
concerned about the children of this
community
again this case really took a turn once
police could get into dezan's cell phone
but it was a challenge because it was
locked velani says investigators used a
brute force technique where they tried
different passcodes over and over again
they did it so many times the battery of
the phone expanded before they could
eventually get into that phone back to
you